no one has worked harder to deal with
the violence used by individuals using
weapons than i have
i strongly strongly urge my republican
friends in the congress who even refuse
to bring up the house pass bill
to bring it up now this has to
end it's a national embarrassment the
folks who own guns
they support universal background checks
majority of them
think we should not be selling assault
weapons who in god's name
needs a weapon that can hold
a hundred rounds and i'm not going to
give up until it's done
president baden this afternoon in the
rose garden with the japanese prime
minister
asked a question about gun control
legislation
after a series of recent events
shootings including last night in
indianapolis
the killing of eight at that fedex
facility we'll start there with our
panel let's bring in
bill bennett former education secretary
host of the bill bennett show podcast
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment
and inclusion capital and tom bevin real
clear politics co-founder and president
tom i want to start with you
at one point the president said in
pushing for this
legislation that that these shootings
uh happen every day what does get talked
about a lot is what happens in chicago
on the streets of chicago and you're
right there
what about the prospects of any kind of
gun legislation there are
multiple efforts by democrats but the
prospects in this environment
yeah i mean biden can talk all he wants
and he can certainly he has used his
executive authority to to do what he can
but it's really nibbling around the
edges the only way that anything's going
to get done
is if it gets done through congress and
you look at a 50-50 senate
the bills that pass the house are not
going to pass the senate and you also
look at joe biden approval rating
from quinnipiac that came out earlier
this week 39
percent on guns uh and only six percent
among republicans 34
among independents and so you put all
those things together
and it does not seem he can stand up
there and he can talk and he can give
speeches
he can implore republicans to act but
unless he's able to sit down and
negotiate with the republicans in the
senate
to find out what is doable what can pass
the congress nothing's going to get done
bill it depends on the issue that you
ask about as far as the latest polling
on his approval but pew overall
about the biden approval is at 59
percent uh
for for the presidency he he was asked a
question about priorities
and legislation where where do you think
guns fall
oh you're asking me i'm sorry bill
bennett yes sir
okay i'm sorry sorry yeah well you know
about that question i was curious
uh i don't have a reporter's ear you do
but that was the first question by the
ap he rattled off an answer
six seven items did he know that
question was coming just just a question
i have
uh i think it's a very high priority for
him because he thinks that's a
very powerful issue for his base and
he's right it is a powerful
issue for his base but as tom just
pointed out the polls don't go his way
the other problem that he has is
something called the second amendment of
the constitution of the united states
he's wrong about the mass shootings in
terms of the numbers and i'm glad you
brought up chicago uh you know
add up the number of people killed in
so-called mass shootings
which get tons of publicity put that up
against the chicago weekend shootings by
criminals
not necessarily by the mentally deranged
but by criminals and you'll see that the
chicago numbers
are higher so there are a lot of
obstacles to this
and they're just looking in the wrong
place a lot of these problems uh
having to do with the mass so-called
mass shootings are mental illness
problems
and we you know opened up our
institutions in the eighties and
nineties
ninety percent of people who were in
those mental institutions got out a lot
of them should have
but a lot of them shouldn't have
harold as far as priorities there's a
lot that this administration is trying
to do
with a very small majority in both
chambers
thoughts well as it relates to guns and
thanks for having me on and happy friday
as it relates to guns ninety percent of
americans support
common sense background checks i believe
that's the last
polling data it's between 85 to 90
percent that's something congress
should just do i do agree that the
violence on the streets in a lot of
urban areas across the country
they've got to address that differently
uh without
question the talk around whether or not
we should
be able to track these guns because most
of these guns in these communities in
these urban areas where a lot of these
this
the awful the gang violence is happening
these people are not going into gun show
going to gun shows or going to gun
stores and buying these guns we should
have some way of
tracking how those guns make it to gang
members wherever they may be in the
country
but that's a broader conversation i hope
the president's willing to tackle it i'm
glad he's willing to put
that 60 approval rating on the line
on a matter as serious and it's
devastating and as we saw
yesterday in indianapolis as fatal as
that can be well tom just very quickly
wrapping up this
topic um chicago has some of the
strictest gun laws in the country
we do and it does it comes down our
problem in chicago is
is gang violence i mean it's just and it
ravages certain sections of the city
um and it's been a problem that that uh
the mayors of this town
who have all been democrats have just
been unwilling to address
yeah i mean they all they all you know
give lip service to it but but the
fundamental
what actually has to happen uh to solve
the issue
uh they haven't been willing to tackle
and so it remains a problem and remember
a problem not just in chicago but in
other urban areas around the country